und matthias becker sprechen wir noch
etwas genauer über diese gigantische
razzia matthias du beschäftigst dich
auch schon sehr lange mit klaren
strukturen hier in berlin
warum dieser gigantische aufwand heute
hier in berlin
man darf nicht vergessen wir reden hier
von lupenreiner oka das sind
schwerbewaffnete skrupellose täter und
da geht die polizei kein risiko ein und
nimmt spezialeinheiten sek aber auch die
gsg9 lokal organisierte kriminalität
dafür steht das clan value hier in
berlin speziell diese familie remo wie
lief die razzia ab gab es gegenwehr
offensichtlich hatte man ja die
befürchtung gehabt dass es gegen der
gibt es schwer bewaffnet gsg9 hast
gesagt sek ja natürlich man hat auch
also vorangegangen sind monatelanger
observation aller beteiligten man hat er
recht früh ganz klar die hinweise auf
diese bandenmitglieder und deswegen
hatte mann observiert
heute sind auch noch hubschrauber zum
einsatz gekommen wir haben ja auch eine
festnahme die aus einem fahrenden objekt
heraus aus einem auto erfolgte und da
ist der zugriff nachts um drei geschehen
und das alles muss man halt sehen dieser
dieser apparat an den ganzen objekten
dafür sind ja polizeien von vier
bundesländern beteiligt gewesen und das
ist halt das dass das große die logistik
wie wurde vor ort reagiert auf die
festnahmen von der familie von den
klaren strukturen hört man das schon
etwas ja also ich habe heute morgen
gleich telefoniert und da ist mir gesagt
man passt auf das war kein klingel ging
die sind also gleich mit ihrer ramme und
ihren vorschlag reimann sind die
aufmarschieren haben sich im treppenflur
angeschlichen denn sind sie teilweise
schlagartig explosions zeitgleich um 6
uhr in den betreffenden wohnungen
eingefallen eine gegen der gibt es da
nicht da ist ein verschlafener ein
aufschrecken die bandenmitglieder ja
meistens auch nachts noch sehr aktiv
sind nicht zu erwarten gewesen
du hast gesagt eine wochenlange
monatelange arbeit
stets vorgeschaltet sozusagen vor dieser
aktion heute die hat man dann versuchte
beweise zu finden wie sicher ist man
sich von behördlicher seite das remmo
dass der emo plan dahinter steckt hinter
dem raub aus dem grünen gewölbe also die
hinweise auf das grüne gewölbe und deren
täter waren ganz früh sehr konkret das
war ein sogenannter v männer sind männer
aus der szene die die hinweise gleich
konkret auf die familie
die großfamilie gegeben haben dann gab
es noch das überwachungssystem an der
autobahn des berühmt- berüchtigte käse
das kennen wir von der vermissten
schülerin rebecca auch da waren die
fahrer sehr erfolgreich so konnte man
auch die abfahrt mit dem taxi ähnlichen
auto der mutmaßlichen täter auf die spur
nach berlin verfolgen wir sind bild und
wir liefern dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren